[Musique]
est-ce que tu crois qu'a près de la
vendredi au changement de peau au changement de
la vie qu'on devient ouverte par
exemple et que tout recommence ici
crois-toi, oui ça l'est
vrai sur les sérums du mme
Fort plz l'un cé de
[Musique]
l'autre parmi les arbres parmi les
autres devi
[Musique]
désir crois qu'on sera mme
ciel et rentrer nous pour la
[Musique]
nuit au chalet du mme
nid est-ce que tu crois qu'a près la
vendredi au changement de peau au changement de
ven
et qu'on devient fleur par
exemple et qu'on devient fleur par
exemple et que tout recommence
ici crois-tu que si cela est
vrai on rejoint le mme
bouquet pour une Petite
fille qui Ne saura pas nos
des secrets plus qu'un simple coup de
doigt nous tuera une seconde
Tu étais au goût d'un quel vase
important puisque nous fanons
ensemble semble est-ce que tu crois qu'a
près du
Vendredi IL et Encore
vie qu'on qui reviendra
[Musique]
humains après un long très long
chemin crois-tu que si cela est
vrai sur sera du mme
quel tout recommencer
ici après la vie après la
[Musique]
ven